good evening everyone and welcome to the
second cabinet meeting of the month
firstly apologies for absence
we have apologies from Council of
lalibela P thank you
next item declaration of interest by
councillors do we have any nope the next
item is to confirm the minutes of the
meeting that we had last week on the
night of January they haven't been
finalized yet so they will follow we'll
pick them up at our next cabinet meeting
next month next item to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
questions by councillors and matters
referred by the overview and scrutiny or
joint ordered and standards committees
thank you moving on the forthcoming
decisions Lister's is the next item has
everyone had a chance to look at this
any any comments anyone hasn't changed
material since last week okay we'll just
note that thank you that brings me on to
the next item which is BCA 1930 the
draft general fund budget for 2020 to
2021 I'm pleased to introduce report BCA
1934 the so 2030 for the 2020 to 2021
general fund budget and four-year
outlook the report contains details of
the draft revenue and capital budgets
and the council strategic financial aid
it will enable us to Dave to consider
key aspects of the draft 2020 to 2021
budget and make any recommendations to
feed into the final budget report next
month it will also enable us to consider
the medium-term position and ensure it
is sustainable we have already had very
helpful briefings to facilitate our
understanding of the key elements of the
budget and the four-year outlook the
government has confirmed that the fair
funding a review the business rates
review and the business rates reset have
all been deferred by 12 months to 2021
to 2022
however the recently announced
provisional financial settlement for
2020 to 21 does give us an additional
funding of 265 thousand pounds and
details of this are provided in Section
4.14 of the report we have a sound
financial strategy that responds
effectively to the changing funding
landscape for local government there's
strategy aims principles and approach
that set out in section 6 of the report
but in summary we must continue with our
efforts to become self-sufficient
through maximizing our income streams
continue to make efficiencies and
productivity savings and also continue
to find new ways of working the general
fund budget setting is just a part of
producing a medium-term outlook for our
finances which is both sensible and
sustainable that's why during the
lengthy budgeting process we do spend a
considerable amount of time working on
projecting the four-year outlook details
of the foundering pressures and savings
in income for the next four years that
provided in sections 8.2 to 8.1 eight of
the report core to our funding is the
need to have a strong council tax base
and so from the perspective of the four
year outlook the numbers do produce
still do produce a compelling case for
the need for council tax increases each
year and so for 2022 2021 we will do
this at the maximum level allowed
without requiring a referendum a 5-pound
per year which equates to 3.1 percent
for a bandy property reducing to 2
percent thereafter along with the most
welcomed 2.5 1 percent growth in the
bandy equivalent number of properties
for 2020 to 2021 and why 1.5 percent per
annum thereafter this will ensure that
we can grow our council tax revenues to
help offset the ongoing cost pressures
that we face since 2011 to 2012 the
council has achieved cumulative savings
and income of seventeen point four
million pounds through shared services
efficiencies better use of technology
and maximizing commercial opportunities
thereby vindicating the bold decisions
that have been made during that period
further savings in income of 2.6 million
pounds have already been identified for
2020 21 and
and the details are provided in section
eight point one eight the general fund
budget today requires five hundred and
twelve thousand pounds of the 2020 to
2021 new homes bonus receipts 1.2
million pounds of section of 31 grants
and 227,000 pounds to the Royal to
services delivery grant and finally
three hundred and four thousand pounds
from our EMR preserves in order to
achieve a balanced budget it should be
noted here that the three hundred and
four thousand pounds from reserves is
only half the amount we transferred last
year and the good news is that only 49
percent of the anticipated new homes
bonus will be required which will enable
us to transfer the rest to the
transformation fund details the new
homes bonus funding are provided in
sections to eight point six eight point
ten of the report the overall budget gap
for this period is described in sections
819 to eight point two to an amount
accumulative one point three two million
pounds and significant income or savings
or both will be needed to address this
the good news however is that we are
predicting a budget surplus of five
hundred and forty two thousand pounds
for 2020 to 2021 and this being the
unused new homes bonus that will go to
the transformation fund the reserve
levels are detailed in paragraph seven
point five table 3 whilst we had to use
a large amount for the 2019 to 2020
budget fakes of new homes bonus
contribution the level at the end of
March 2021 is expected to improve with a
transformation fund a much healthier and
48,000 pounds even within this
improvement the level of reserves
excluding sill drops by 10% over the two
years from March 2019 to March 2021 and
so this does require close attention
attention in the future the capital
program is set out in the appendix B and
the plan spend for 2022 2021 is 12 point
1 million pounds the main areas are just
under 1 million pound on housing grants
eight point seven million pound
investment in Cisco and just under 1
million pound on the continuation of the
refurbishment of the leisure centers the
three major differences from this time
last year we're not expecting to
complete the furthest if Co income until
20 21 to 22 22 now the Bellevue capital
investment has been delayed until 2021
to 2022 and we have yet to dip into the
strategic land and property investment
fund the capital and the investment
strategy will have further details of
the council's borrowing capacity and the
impacts of the capital program and this
will this will be presented to cabinet
in February along with a final budget
report following review by the joint
audit and standards committee finally we
will be making changes to the empty
property discount the background to this
is explained in sections 11 point one to
eleven point seven we will keep the
level of discount for unoccupied and
unfurnished properties at twenty five
percent but reduce the period from three
months to twenty eight days after which
full council taxes payable the
uninhabitable discount will remain
unchanged at 25 percent for twelve
months if this had been in place in 2018
we would have raised it further fifty
three thousand powers in council tax so
that concludes my report introduction of
the the budget and so I'd like to
propose the recommendations that you'll
find in paragraphs three point one three
three twelve one two three point three
of your report and may I have a seconder
please capsule Mel BC do I have any
questions from anyone or any comments
that anyone would like to make
okay well castle castle parka sorry just
as the last layer chat response waiting
for colleagues to jump in but with
regards chair to the the unoccupied non
furnished reduction it's not
specifically mentioned within the report
but i i mean i'm aware of the fact that
there are circumstances for example to
somebody's in long-term care or indeed
if somebody has always become deceased
and and maybe the property is is waiting
probate from the administration whatever
so how our properties treated in those
circumstances for clarification because
it's not explicitly recorded yeah if the
property is unoccupied eighty is exempt
from council tax while awaiting a grant
of probate or a letter of administration
and following that that exception will
continue for a further six months after
the grant of probate beyond that if it's
still unoccupied but furnished in a
hundred percent castle tax is applicable
because it's regarded as a second home
but if it's unfurnished and unoccupied
then the the reduction scheme that i
just announced will come into play so
there'll be a 25% reduction for 28 days
but that's that's a long term time into
the future there is that exact exam
period while awaiting and also beyond
grant of probate any other questions
from anyone and other members
okay then right well we've had this
recommended and seconded wood before I
get take it to a vote are there any any
comments anyone wants to make this is
last opportunity Castle Osbourne Thank
You mr. chairman and yeah I think as you
said in your introduction and all
members have been very well briefed over
the last few months so we are aware of
the budget in the contents of it I just
like to thank the officers for coming up
with a budget that is a balanced budget
without us having to reduce any services
to our residents so well done to the
star and it's it's a good budget Castle
Busbee thank you
it's visits good to have some positive
[ __ ] rather than always be look just
the same a few quit here and there the
only concern I have I guess is it's for
the future longer-term future I do think
we're entering a phase where the way
we've done things in the past won't be
relevant for the future in many ways and
I think transition or Tran the
transformation budget the money that
we've got in there will be very valuable
I think we've got to look at some of the
services that we provide all the
services we don't yet provide that we
perhaps we should do maybe bus routes
bus services to villages and things like
that
I think there's demand upon communities
but perhaps not necessarily aware of but
we're going to need to do something
about and I just see that with the
climate change as well what we do in
five years time will be significantly
different from the way we've done things
in the past and therefore just taking
the past then adding X percent as we may
have done in the in the past won't be
relevant going for
I think we need to give it some
attention over the next 12 to 18 months
that's awful thank you yeah clearly
we're in a fast changing landscape and
there is a program of transformation and
improvement that is going to be
continual over the next few years and
yes that will obviously mean some-some
reassessment of the budget but and the
our obligations under our climate
emergency acknowledgement will certainly
require us to find some additional
funding but at the moment we're waiting
for the task force to report back before
we know exactly what what needs to be
done there but yes transformation fund
while it is more healthy is certainly
going to play a part in in helping to
finance those things but just following
on from what castle also said you know
certainly that it's been an excellent
Java game providing us with the balanced
budget we not just in the past year but
since I've been an elected member we've
not cut services which is excellent so
we're doing pretty well I think but as I
said the the for the next four years are
going to be pretty crucial we have that
1.3 2 million which we've got to address
but one way or another we will okay then
um right all those in favor then of the
draft general fund budget thank you
right moving on then is paper BCA 1931
the draft HR a budget for 2022 2021
right so I'm police drew introduced
rapport PCA 1931 for the 2020 to 2021
HRA budget and for year outlook he
covers both the HRA revenue account and
the capital program it will enable us
today to consider key aspects of the
draft 20 22 22 22 on budget and make any
recommendations to feed into the final
budget before next month we have a sound
30 year business plan which has resulted
in Fable positions for both revenue and
capital for 2022 2021 we have been
helped by the end of the ending of the
annual 1% rent reduction proposed by the
welfare reform and work Act of 2016 the
Act does now allows rents to be
increased by CPI which is currently 1.7
percent plus 1% for five years from 2020
to 2021 the remaining 25 years of the
business plan are based on the annual
ring increase of CPI only the business
plan is attached at Appendix B and shows
additional detail for years 1 to 10
section 2 of the report shows the
predicted movement in reserves over the
next 10 years it shows a slight
reduction from 12 point 7 million to 12
point two million and section 6.3 shows
the debt repayment profile for the next
30 years with all debt being repaid by
2049 to 2050 a fundamental review of the
housing service has been undertaken
during 2019 to 2020 to identify savings
efficiencies and income generation
opportunities to achieve a sustainable
business plan into the future the scope
of this review is provided in Section
seven point one of the report we are
continuing with our aspiration to
increase our housing stock new homes of
all types provide us with new homes
bonus and council tax but additional
council housing also delivers rental
income and wider financial and social
benefits the table in section 10 of the
report sets out the HRA budget for 2020
to 2021 based on a 2.7 percent
rent increase and highlights the
movement from the 2019 to 2020 budget a
surplus position is forecast at 298
thousand pounds which is a significant
improvement on the 2019 2020 position
which was a deficit of 193 thousand
pounds and this has been achieved by
reducing birth of revenue and capital
budgets
and those are given in table 10.1 but
and we are also proposing to transfer
this surplus to the HRA in reserves
you'll see from the report that key
adverse movements are a reduction in
income of 175 thousand pounds which are
primarily due to the forthcoming year
being a 52-week year whereas last year
was fifty three weeks and also delays in
new builds there is an increase of two
hundred thirty seven thousand pounds in
general management costs due to staff
costs and the transfer of the ICT budget
to the HRA there's an increase of fifty
seven thousand and fifty six thousand
pound story for repairs and maintenance
and an increase of sixty eight thousand
pounds for property services said again
sees the fair favorable variances most
notably a reduction in revenue
contribution to capital of 1.0 for seven
million pounds due to the revised
capital program income and savings
opportunity so that have been made and
are proposed for 2022 2021 identified in
section eight point two we are proposing
to increase the sheltered housing
charges by two pound per week to ensure
recovery of the actual cost it is
proposed that utility charges to kept at
the same level as the current year
garage rates will also remain at the
current level income increases or
savings continues to be reflected in the
budget and will be monitored during the
year next year we'll see a focus on all
contracts those more than fifty thousand
pounds to review the terms of each of
these and to to identify savings
opportunities as well as the decision on
the long term future of building
services by a joint venture with
flashing housing a review of the HRA
business plan will also be undertaken
finally I would like to note that right
by sales were lower than those projected
in the business plan in twenty eighteen
to nineteen baver sold only fifteen
properties against an original
projection of twenty seven sales for the
capital program sexual section five
point four of the report summon up
summarizes the capital expenditure and
financing for the next four years up to
twenty twenty three to twenty twenty for
the section six point four gives a
graphical view of the expenditure
paragraphs 11.1 to 11 point three oh and
and it's a provide more detail working
with I see need to identify a
development sites we are aiming to build
229 affordable homes of 15 for shared
ownership we are anticipating a curative
budget of just under 50 1.2 million
pounds for the capital program which
includes twenty six point nine million
pounds for the new builds and
acquisitions to be financed from a
number of sources as shown in Section
5.4 and the appendix and that includes
eleven point seven million pounds of
borrowing no strategic priority reserves
will be route that will be used to
finance this program so that concludes
my HRA draft budget report and I'd like
to propose the recommendations provided
in paragraphs 3.1 to 3.8 and may have a
second please councillor Osborn thank
you any questions anyone
Castle Busbee yeah I can't say I'm
particularly keen about seeing rents go
up but CPI plus 1% is very reason why we
have to do it greater than CPR is what
the government is allowing us to do and
are recommending when we did the
original 30-year business plan that's
what we were allowed to do and that was
what built in over the 30-year period
obviously the HOA has taken a bit of a
hit over the last four years because
we've had to do the the 1% reductions so
really wanting to take the opportunity
to reinstate some of that but perhaps an
important point to note is that even
with the increase people will still be
paying less for their rent than they
were four years ago
so it doesn't you know replace that four
years worth of read up 1% reductions
that we've had so although it's an
increase proposed for next year they'll
still be well below the levels and I
have seen I think it was yesterday I saw
something published that the government
are replying inflation to the local
housing allowance which is what benefits
are based on so our tenants who receive
benefits will get that inflationary
uplift in their in their housing benefit
as well Thank You Catherine Custer
Osborne thank you mr. Chen on the same
subject and those that are low income
will obviously be able to apply for
increase in their benefits to cover that
increase in their own on a positive note
just to reassure you it doesn't Abel the
council to ensure that we can provide a
really good standard of homes and and to
build and acquire more homes as well so
it's a positive message and as I say
it's it's those are a low income and
claim benefits
thank you any questions from other
members so so if nobody has any further
comment on on this castles wall just
obviously how did you know mr. German I
was concerned about the two pound
increase for sheltered housing services
as well as the increase that they would
have in the rent but again to reassure
people that it is actually before the
increase it was subsidizing our general
needs rents up to the charge of 58,000
which is a lot of money by increasing
the service charge for two pounds per
week it reduces that gap to 31,000 so
it's still being subsidized but it is
being subsidized by quite a considerable
amount less so that was one of the
reasons why obviously we had to do the
increase yes and the utility utility
charges are being held at the same level
yeah just lopaka can I spit come from
something that you said there chair that
in respective right to buy sales they
were down significantly and what was
projected so why not so much why were
they you know why were they if you were
sold but how did we come by the
projection of 27 in the first place I
think that was based on my previous
experience if anyone likes you I think
it's based on what had gone in the past
years yeah it's an average over the past
number of years and obviously we will in
future will need to revisit that but it
is what it is isn't a lot we can do
about that one way or the other
there are benefits to that and there
disadvantages so we just have to go sir
oswald again on that subject it could be
that there's
currently consultation out on the right
to buy I think we've been waiting for an
outcome from that for about eight months
so it could be that prospective buyers
are holding back until the outcome of
that consultation is known in case
there's any major changes to it thank
you
Castle McCraw if something raised since
you last us I would just like to comment
that it's interesting to see the
building of council houses reverses a
trend that we haven't actually seen in
local government in England and Wales in
the last 30 years and I think that's
something that the council should point
to and make a liberabit point regardless
of the risks of the right to buy just
something I think that should be
trumpeted loudly yes thank you yes in
common with all stock holding
authorities we're trying to increase our
numbers now it is something that we do
need as as part of our balanced housing
stock and to meet our numbers that we've
got to deliver over the next few years
thank you okay well if if they're
because suppose we on that subject the
UM appendix B which shows the next 15-20
years so ten years of income and costs
are the the rental income figures
reflecting the potential building of new
council houses or adjust the existing
council houses projected forward it's
all factored in isn't it yeah yes for
fact is it and so how many a year was it
was a hundred years I say it will be in
in accordance with the capital program
so the ones that we're planning to build
over the last couple of years the
figures that council awards said then
that's what will built into the business
plan
beyond the next couple of years I'm not
sure do we do we still assume even more
coming on yes yeah so over over the 30
year period we are planning for adding
to the stock because we've got the debt
cap anymore on the HRA so we can't
afford to to do more than we used to be
able to correspond on that again on that
subject there is a piece of work being
done to ascertain whether we want to
increase the target which was 214 over
four years of that 214 we've acquired or
built to date 104 and we're on target to
deliver the remainder of that target but
that piece of work is being done within
the next few months to look to see
whether we need to borrow more money
whether we can take it out the reserves
that we've got to increase that target
so that will be coming forward very
within the next few months and in
parallel to identify sites okay everyone
right well the recommendations have been
proposed and seconded may have a vote
everyone in favor of the draft HRA
budget
thank you well that brings the meeting
to a close our next meeting is Tuesday
the length of every 5:30 p.m. thank you
everyone